there's no supervillain quite like fan
oohs the mad Titan he's been a menace to
the Marvel Universe since 1973 when he
made his debut and Ironman number 55 and
few villains have proven is formidable
despite his long history in Marvel
Comics Thanos has never been as
high-profile as he is now you probably
already know that he's a nihilist cosmic
warlord who set on assembling the
Infinity Gauntlet allowing him to wipe
out life as we know it set that aside
though and you'll find a ton of
fascinating components to the character
that are slightly lesser-known this is
the untold truth of Thanos Tommy's
Hannegan aesthetic inspiration fan OHS
is far from the most unique creation in
the history of comics created by writer
and artist jim Starlin fan o shares many
similarities with characters created by
another comics luminary Jack Kirby
specifically Kirby's work on DC's new
gods series
Starlin initially based anos on the new
God's character Metron a genius
celestial observer to the events of the
DC Universe many of thought fan owes his
inspiration to be the DC character
Darkseid but according to Starlin that
wasn't initially the case speaking in a
1998 interview with comic book artist
Starlin said you'd think that Thanos was
inspired by Darkseid but that was not
the case when I showed up in my first
stano's drawings if he looked like
anybody it was Metron Roy took one look
at the guy in the Metro on like chair
and said beef him up if you're gonna
steal one of the New Gods at least rip
off Darkseid the really good one
fortunately the resemblance is only
skin-deep the two characters have vastly
different motivations and levels of
empathy and fan osis fleetingly fought
alongside heroes before we didn't get
safe to say that's not really Darkseid
style
[Music]
my name is this may come as a shock from
the looks of him but fan hasta sins from
a race of aliens that actually look more
or less human fan OHS is a carrier of
the deviant gene sort of the equivalent
of a mutant in his race his mother
father and the rest of his family are
members of a super-powered alien race
called the Eternals living on titan one
of Saturn's moons they look human and
when his mother suisse on became
pregnant they expected him to look the
same when Thanos was born however one
look at him sent all expectations out
the window including the name his mother
intended to give him before she realized
stano's was a deviant his mother
intended to name him died on
however when her child was born she was
horrified by his mutation and upon
looking into his eyes she realized he
was the harbinger of the universe's
ultimate destruction I made a huge
mistake there's a lot more messing up
this mother-son relationship than just
unfulfilled expectations in a gross chin
Suisan tried to execute Thanos as a
child infantile successfully returned
the favor later in life they're complex
tumultuously Naha n-- the shorthand is
the butterfly effect a butterfly flapped
its wings and retaining central park'
that ran instead essentially collecting
the gems the Marvel Cinematic Universe
spent more than ten years building up
fan OSes search for the powerful six
Infinity stones or gems as they used to
be known but it only took him two comic
books to accomplish a goal that's taken
a decade to get done on screen with the
mad Titan snatching up the gems one by
one in a 1990 comic called the fan oohs
quest the two-part story saw Thanos
traveling the universe and liberating
the six gems from their owners and they
were all in very different hands
compared to their cinematic counterparts
first Thanos attacked the imprisoned
in-betweener
stealing the Green soul gym from his
head next he liberated the red power gym
from the champion in a physical contest
installed the time gym from the Gardner
and ageless elder of the universe the
yellow reality gym he pilfered from the
collector who you may remember from
guardians of the galaxy the purple space
gym was taken from the runner and the
blue mine gym was nabbed from the grand
master yes that Grand Master from Thor
Ragnarok
[Music]
all of these foes fell with the
surprising quickness when challenged
clearing the way for Thanos to assume
the powers of a god in the Titanic 1991
event series the Infinity Gauntlet
courting death many of Thanos has
stories chronicled the Titans obsessive
passion for the living personification
of death it's a relationship that was
foreshadowed by his very name jim
Starlin originally came up with the
character of panels while taking a
college psychology class he based Thanos
his personality off of the Freudian
concept of the death Drive in other
words the psychological impulse to end
one's own existence
his name is reminiscent of fana toast
the Greek mythological figure who was
said to represent death in Marvel Comics
cannon death is an actual person a
skeletal female entity who is sometimes
referred to as lady or mistress death
while Thanos is completely in love with
her death often refuses to entertain his
advances or even acknowledge his
existence leading Thanos to lash out and
seek attention through his universe
destroying scheme while death does
eventually entertain a romance with fan
oohs to say it's complicated would be
putting it lightly
it certainly wasn't worth all of the
destruction in the end Thanos his battle
against the universe of strongest heroes
was all done for the sake of impressing
a girl she's not even all that
good-looking my own worst enemy all of
fan else's bluster covers up a lot of
insecurities as both the Infinity
Gauntlet and the character solo outings
have shown Santos is surprisingly
something of a self defeating sad sack
on the surface his goals would seem to
be the same as any other supervillain
world domination and destruction
however Thanos has motivations transcend
typical villainy
he believes in oblivion like a religion
and all but warships death itself in his
own twisted way he believes he's doing
the right thing the universe is unworthy
of existence therefore it falls on him
to give it what it deserves the nihilism
doesn't stop with his view towards all
other life it applies to him as well not
even Thanos is worthy this is why fan
OHS despite his power never manages to
stay on top for too long it's firmly
established in Infinity Gauntlet that he
ultimately fails because he allows
himself to he will always subconsciously
leave a hole in his plans that the
heroes can exploit to bring about his
defeat as much as he believes that the
universe deserves to die he doesn't
believe himself worthy of the task at
hand for such a formidable of
worldly figure that's a pretty human
flaw fan aside amalgam comics is a
pretty interesting corner of comics lore
a joint venture between Marvel and DC it
featured characters that were you
guessed it amalgamations of Marvel and
DC characters the world of amalgam is
populated by heroes like Bruce Wayne
agent of shield and Doctor Strange fade
and it didn't stop with heroes the
universe also featured amalgamations of
villains from both publishers and you
can probably guess who fan OHS was
paired with Thanos and dark side combine
to form fan o site like darkside fan o
side rules the planet of apocalypse and
like fan O's he has an ambition to wipe
out the universe in the events that led
to their combining in the amalgam
universe Darkseid actually insulted
Thanos calling Thanos just a pale
imitation of him a funny nod to Thanos
his origins amalgams comics weren't
exactly classics but they were a whole
lot of fun kicking it with the boys one
might reasonably assume the Marvel
Universe only had room for one
nihilistic death Titan that would be
incorrect one of the more interesting
corners of Thanos history involves a
personal army of clones he made of
himself these clones are known as the
Fano side and are formed by fan of
splicing his DNA with that of other
Marvel heroes and villains
there's Omega across between Panos and
Galactus for instance fan OHS creates
the fan Oh site to test the abilities of
enemies and allies alike eventually he
considers them failures and abandons
them shockingly the fan aside don't take
this betrayal particularly well they
band together and being an army of fan
O's clones attempt to bring about the
ultimate end of the universe
luckily they fail given fan OSes general
tendencies an army of fan O's clones
ending up trying to destroy the universe
isn't any kind of surprise my brother
the lover no matter how many times he
impressively destroys the universe or
lies himself with the good guys fan OHS
will never be as loved as his brother
starfox no not that starfox the starfox
of the Marvel Universe also called eros
is a carefree easygoing flirt his
charming personality is only amplified
by his superpowers which include a sort
of pheromone effect he can make people
within 25 feet of him feel joy
effectively drawing them to him when
cranked up it can provoke romantic
feelings he's basically a sentient
Marvin Gaye record which is pretty tough
to compete with when you're a lumpy
purple death Titan starfox couldn't be
any more different from his brother
Thanos and that's probably a good thing
you imagine if those parents had to put
up with not just one but two lousy kids
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]